and NBS you were never you were never
really a real atheist just kidding I
myself go to Hindu temples with family
but I don't believe are you truly
convinced or is it just a leap of
faith me um good
question uh depends on what you mean by
truly convinced but I would say that uh
describing it more as a as a leap of
faith would be it's actually a better
description yeah and I I I I know I
didn't think of of just saying it like
that but this actually it's actually a
good description it's also um there
there is a part of me and uh it's it's
just I'm not I'm not sure how to say
this H because people expect like and
this also contradicts how I approached
religion in the past and people are
going to say oh what why would you join
some without knowing it's 100% true but
the thing is um I started practicing not
because I was convinced that it's true
but rather because I felt like it is
better and I would I would hope that
it's true and it might be true and I
might just simply not know and there are
lots of lots of things about it that I
might not be able that I'm not able to
completely refute and and all that and
um I thought to myself I could simply
start going that way what is there to
lose anyway it's also kind of um funny
because uh David like many others have
often said
um that if you are an atheist it's
basically you exist you live you go
through life you you you search you
analyze and so on you believe in in what
is true and what is not true and then in
the end you die that's it that's it you
did
uh so living a living a life of an
atheist um doesn't really lead anywhere
in the end you just die anyway and if if
the whole world all exists for no other
bigger purpose purpose no greater
purpose all of existence is just going
to exist and at some point sees existing
or it will just exist forever and ever
and ever for no purpose at all so um if
then in the middle of this right if in
the middle of this uh religion is true
or you know Christianity is true you
could add some great purpose to your
life and live a meaningful great life
believing that Christianity is true is
actually a a better way to look at the
world than believing that there is no
God and Atheism is the correct
analysis if you live your
life being convinced that atheism is the
correct
analysis it's just you just live your
life and you die in the end anyway what
would be what what would be so bad about
simply choosing to live a Christian Life
for example if the Christian life is
going to look better for you for me I I
I I would say uh after many years of
consideration looking at a Christian
Life a Christian Life seemed to be a
much better option for me it's it's a
much better option and it's a much much
much happier option it's a much more uh
it's an option with much more Serenity
you know with much more meaning instead
of the whole uh the the void and the
hopelessness the the
nothingness I always uh forever just
depended on on simply wanting to pursue
uh
truth and always go with what I'm 100%
sure of when I went to church I actually
had a conversation with a with an
Orthodox Christian Monk and he said
something very very interesting which
kind of changed changed everything about
uh about how I viewed the world and I'm
not entirely sure how how how how I can
um you know um Express or paraphrase
what he said to me I kind of wish I had
that I had that recorded or something
but he basically um after I told him
that for that for the last 10 years I
only pursued um the you know facts and
only went for something if I knew that
it's 100% uh true he said to me
um with Christianity nobody ever expects
you to know that that something is 100%
true which is why we call it faith if
with something else like with like with
atheism you want to go for it and you
want to uh make your next step always
always uh knowing that that whatever you
you you make you make a step toward is
100% true then uh you are going to make
steps and rely only on your mind you
will be led by your mind by a mind that
you yourself know is very limited and
very weak like all of our minds and
in the
end
sorry in the end um you will not become
a Christian but rather try to find
meaning and find a solution to things in
your life but the irony of it is that
you will live your life with all of your
skepticism and in the end you will not
be able to help yourself you will simply
die and then seize existing what's the
point of that you didn't really help
yourself
all you did was just to be skeptical and
then to die why not just go this path
and I thought you know
what it's kind of that's kind of an
interesting way to look at
things it makes more sense than just
than than than what I did for the last
10 years anyway long story short uh it
was kind of a leap of faith yeah and uh
when I was when I was in a jail
cell and
I had I thought I had come up with the
design argument it turns out other
people came up with the design argument
long before me came up with a kind of
moral argument thought I invented that
uh turns out people had come up with a
moral argument long before me and um
started concluding that it looked like
there was actual good evidence for Jesus
resurrection um thought that I came up
with the conclusion about how the
apostles died suggested that they really
believed what they were dying for and
therefore that they actually saw
something and then the question becomes
what did they see that convinced these
guys that a person who had been
crucified had appeared to them later
what could account for this and so on
anyway but you put all that together and
I can't say I was
like completely or even close to
completely convinced so it was more
along the lines of okay here's what I
here's here's my position and my
trajectory now and I thought there was
no way I was going to take Serious ly
this message of Christianity because I
thought it was stupid and completely
wrong so I wasn't even considering that
but now now that I see okay they've
actually got a case from design and they
got a case from a moral argument for for
God's existence and they actually have a
case for the resurrection and for
Christianity being true at that point it
wasn't I know that this is correct or
I'm completely convinced of this it's
okay I know I know what I I know what I
have on this trajectory and that may
that may this may be the trajectory that
I'm on but I'd kind of be stupid given
my circumstances not to say well okay
what why don't I why don't I give this a
why don't I check this out a bit more
why don't I take a look at this a bit
more why don't I why don't I try praying
and see what happens if not I already
know where I'm going I was I was they
were uh the doctor was saying he was
going to tube feed me the psychiatrist
was saying she wants to send me to uh uh
a more permanent mental hospital and so
on and it's like okay I know where I'm
going on this road I know where I'm
going on this road uh why don't I pray
and see what happens and if that turns
out to be true if Christianity is
actually true maybe there's a different
path for
me and here we are many decades later
crushing Islam and Atheism powerful
[Music]